bismillah hamdulillah Isis Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Deen show now we've had
the great opportunity and we've been
blessed to sit with some of the best of
those who are out there sincerely humbly
trying to educate you on that beautiful
way of life the way of life of all the
messengers of God that way of surrender
and submission sincerely to the creator
of the heavens and earth now by popular
demand people have been requesting
people have been asking why don't you
have this man on the show and you know
what today he's here the true doctor
Odawa
dr. zakir naik when we come back you
don't want to go nowhere Allah is the
only one
is his messenger Allah la ilaha illa
llah
ah ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum waalaikumussalam rental
ever get o hamdulillah I'm very excited
to have you here with us and there's a
pleasure for me to be with you I keep
thinking back we spent a little time
together me and you and use of Estes and
we spent hours together and I know
you're you're very enthusiastic about
giving doubt because you've come so far
Allah has blessed you and I didn't get I
was so tired and I didn't even get a
chance to ask you to for lesson for us
to do something and I made dua say Allah
please make it happen and we're here
together tunnel acceptors in trouble I
mean yes so we're going to get straight
to the topic there's some confusion out
there people are worshipping the Sun
they're worshipping the moon they're
worshipping a man so in this particular
show because you're expert on this topic
we want to give the top reasons why the
creator of the heavens and earth God
Almighty in Arabic we say Allah is not a
man never was a man never tried to be a
man if he analyzed all the majority of
the world except for Islam all the other
majors in the world
they believed that Almighty God became a
human me once or more number of time yes
all the major religions except Islam
they believed that Almighty God is the
once or many times became a human being
and they believed in a serosa funeral
anthropomorphism anthropomorphism means
that Almighty God taking forms and he
becomes a human being and when we ask
them that why does Almighty God have to
become human being so they say that
Almighty God he's so holy he's so pure
he's so noble he does not know the
shortcomings of the human beings he does
not know how do they made me feel when
he's hurt when he's angry when he
requires certain things he doesn't know
the requirements of the human being how
do they feel etcetera that's the reason
Almighty God came into this world and
kamo human being to know what is good
what is bad for the meaning on the face
of it
it sounds to be a very good logic oh
mighty God so holy so pure so noble does
not know the shortcomings of the human
being does not know how a human being
feels when you hurt when he's had
problems so it is found to be good yeah
right tell them that suppose I happen to
manufacture a DVD player yeah I create a
DVD player now because I am a
manufacturer of a DVD player do I have
to become a DVD player to know what is
good what is bad for the DVD player
because I am the manufacturer yeah I am
the creator I do not have to become a
DVD boarder I do I write an instruction
manual
exactly if you want to play the DVD
insert the DVT and press the play button
yes if you want to skip press the skip
button if you want to stop processor
press the stop button I do not have to
become a DVD player to know what is good
or it is matter that you deeply because
I am the creator
similarly Almighty God he is the creator
of the human being so it does not have
to become a human being to know what is
good or bad for him in me what does he
do he chooses a man amongst men and he
communicates with them on a higher level
who we call his messenger the
philosopher North Anna he doesn't have
to come himself and the last and final
message the last 10 fine structure in
manual for the mean means into glorious
quran so that is the reason what they
give foremost that Almighty God became a
human being based on an through
PowerPoint anthropomorphism philosophy
can be argued that it's not required for
the Creator to become the creation yeah
now we have a lot of non-muslims
watching this show and you said in
Arabic word you said Allah can you tell
us what this means Allah by definition
yes it's the best definition I can give
you is go to surah class chapter 112
verse number 1 to felices goal who Allah
had say is allow and only allow summit
Allah the absolute and eternal Lemire in
velum allah he begets not nor begotten
well a miracle local fauna there nothing
like him this is a four line definition
of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala who is
Almighty God
any person says that forensic candidate
is God if that candidate fits in this
poll and definition we Muslims have got
no objection in accepting him as
Almighty God the first is say he's a
lover and only second is Allah who some
earth Allah the absolute an eternal
third is lum unit one amoled he begets
not nor is He begotten and the fourth
way of Allah meeya : o Fernet there is
nothing like him and this sir a class
appointing to me is the touchstone of
theology
Theo means God Lajja me study theology
study of what it is a touchstone of
theology any human being who wants to
identify or verify whether the God he or
she is worshipping is true or not let
him or her put that God to the test of
soul a class if he passes the test he
the true God otherwise he's a fake God
now tell us now it's known commonly that
people take one that is beloved to our
hearts we love him as one of the
mightiest measures of God but many are
claiming that he said he was God that
he's the son of God is some confusion
here what do we have to say about this
if they do agree that most of the
Christians they believe that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he claimed
divinity many mother Christians believe
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
was caught but if you read the Bible
there is not a single unequivocal
statement not a single unambiguous
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says safe
that I am God always they worship me
anywhere in the Bible if any Christian
can point out a single unequivocal
statement a single unambiguous treatment
where Jesus Christ peace be upon him
says says that I am God always they
worship me I am red wrecks of
Christianity in fact to read the Bible
yeah it's mentioned the Gospel of John
chapter number 14 was sommore 28 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said my father
is greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than all Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse number 28 I cast
out devil with the Spirit of God Gospel
of Luke chapter number 11 verse number
20 I with the finger of God cast out
devil Gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 20 I can of my own shall do
nothing as I hear I judge
and my judgment is just for a thick not
maybe level of Almighty God it's
mentioned Gospel of John chapter 5 verse
30 that not my will but God's will
anyone who says it's not my will but
God's will is a Muslim so Jesus casts
please be upon him as a Muslim and there
are several quotation I can give you
with Jesus cash people never claimed
divinity he never said he was God but he
was a Messenger of God it's mentioned in
the Gospel of John chapter number 14
verse 24 Jesus Christ peace be upon him
says that the words that you hear are
not mine but my father's were sent to me
Gospel of John chapter number 17 verse
number 3 says this is life eternal so
that you may know one true God and Jesus
Christ whom thou has sent and it is
clearly mentioned the book of Acts
chapter number two verse number 22 it
says that even of Israel listen to this
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst you by wonders and miracles and
signs which God did Batmen you witness
to it a man approved of God amongst you
by wonders and miracles and signs which
God did man and when he was asked which
of the first of the commandment it's
mentioned the Gospel of Mark chapter
number 12 verse 29 he said the same
thing what Moses I said earlier Shema
Israel Oh at the nod nod if the Hebrew
condition which means your o Israel the
Lord our God is one Lord
now you've been an expert in this area
in this field did Moses Noah Abraham the
first man Adam did they ever worship a
man God a son of God is there anything
any reference to this none of the
prophets of God none of the prophets
mentioned in the Bible right from Adam
peace before him to Jesus Pirogov nor
never never it is a misconception among
the Christians with the church proclaims
that Jesus claimed divinity there is not
a single unequivocal statement in the
Bible with Jesus ever said peace be upon
him that worshiped me or that he forgot
now you said something that's clear
lucid the verses that you gave are easy
to understand but someone says you know
what I think that I heard something from
my preacher he said I in the father are
one no one comes to the Father but me
how do we take this and explain this are
as the first statement you said I and my
father are one
it's a quotation of Gospel of John
sharpening button was going to 30 and my
father ever but you have to go to the
context if you go to the context and
Gospel of John chapter number 10 verse
23 come to know it says that Jesus casts
peace be upon him and entered the temple
in Solomon's porch was some 24 says that
all the G surrounded him all the Jews
the surrounded him and they asked him
that if thou art the Christ place tell
us plainly
so Jesus KSP is we have replies in verse
number 25 that I told you what you
believe not
verse 26 you do not believe me because
you are not my sheep verse 27 my people
who follow me they are my sheep they
listen to me
verse 28 no man can pluck them out of my
hand I give them eternal life
no man can pluck them out of my hand
verse number 29 my father give it to me
is greater than all
no man can plug them out of my father's
hand so if you see the context in verse
number 28 Jesus Christ pfl says that my
followers no one can pluck them out of
my hand
no one can pluck them out of my father's
and verse number 29 what's the method he
said I and my father are one
so in context Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and Almighty God they are one in
purpose but not one as one entity in
context my father is the doctor I am a
doctor and if I say I and my father are
one
it means one in profession it does not
mean as we are joined by one email make
sense here but there is no doctors or
cure you have misunderstood the verse of
the Bible it means one only I said fine
always believe in in dialogue I agree
with the wrong argument and then
disprove if I agree with you that this
one means one in person if you go ahead
in Gospel of John chapter number 17
verse 7 21 it says the jsk says my
father is in me I Indy talking to the
twelve disciples we all are one the same
one is used here same word so do you
mean to say God and Jesus and the twelve
disciples the fourteen words so now I
left to coined a new word instead of
Trinity we have to coin a new word
saying fourteen in one and again further
if you go in Gospel of John chapter 17
verse 23 GSEs Peter says ìand nu in me
to twelve disciples and generous cash
please be affirmed they are 1 that means
13 words so now I have to coined a new
word for 13 words so that
thing if one in purpose now another one
that I mentioned that is very popular
that fit that I am the way the truth and
the life no man cometh either but by me
you go to the last part that no man come
to Father but by me but the full
quotation is from Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 6 which says that
I am the way the truth and the life no
man cometh unto my father but through me
this again point number one it's not
unequivocal statement saying that Jesus
and God please be upon him but if you
read the context to come to know what
does it mean context go to Gospel of
John chapter 14 verse number 1 it says
that why you troubled if you believe in
God believe in me also verse number 2
says in my father's mansion there are
many houses I am going there to prepare
a place for you if it was not so I
wouldn't have told you there was
continuous and it says that I am going
to prepare a place for you now you know
where I go so one disciple asked him
that master we do not know where you go
then you say I am the way the truth and
the life no man cometh unto the father
but through me when context it means
that this we have to reach God you have
to follow the pathway of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him every messenger at his
time he was the way the truth and the
life no man came unto Almighty God but
shouldna messenger at the time of Moses
Moses was the way the truth and the life
no man came unto Almighty God but
through Moses at the time of Jesus most
verily because he was a Messenger of God
at his time he was the way the truth and
the life no man came unto Almighty God
but Jesus case please before today the
last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him
so mamasa loss column is the way and the
truth and the life no man can reach
Almighty God except through the pathway
of domicile assalam but that does not
make Prophet Muhammad as God not wrong
as jesus cash baby acuna said in the
Gospel of John step number 16 verse
number 11 to 14 I have many things to
send to you but he cannot bear them now
for he when the Spirit of Truth shall
come he shall guide you into all truth
he should not speak of himself all that
here shall he speak he shall go to find
me this is talking about Prophet
Muhammad too so it means this verse
means that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was the messenger for my Tivo a
couple more points so much to cover so
little time tell us
some people say what god is almighty he
knows all he has power over all things
he could do anything what does this mean
so they say that God can do anything so
why can't he become a man that's the
common argument that put forth that why
are you restricting the powers of God
exactly God can do anything everything
so while you're restricting the powers
of Almighty God and I tell them for sake
of argument I agree with you God can do
anything and everything and you say that
God can become a human being so if I
agree with you God can become a human
being then you have to realize once God
becomes a human being he see this to be
God
we say God can become a human have no
problem but is finished but you cannot
say there is a god man if you say there
is a god man God who has become man and
has the power of God it does not make
sense why because it by definition God
is immortal human being is mortal you
can either have an immortal person or a
mortal person you can have a person who
is immortal and mortal at the same time
it is meaningless does it make sense
that innocence Almighty God has no
beginning
you mean means have a beginning you
can't have a person who has no beginning
and has a beginning at the same time it
is meaningless
Almighty God have got no end you mean
mean have an end you cannot have a
person who has no end and has an another
the same time it's meaningless it's like
telling eyes or tall short man you got
tall man or short man it is it is it is
absolutely you cannot use a word like in
tall short yeah use about tournement
short man or a medium men you cannot all
short man you can have fat thin man
similarly you can't have a god man yes
for example Almighty God does not
require to eat you mean means if I to
eat yes Quran says in surah anaam
chapter 6 verse 14 it is Allah who feeds
everyone but does not require to be fed
we human being we're rest and sleep
Almighty God does not require
residentially Quran says instead of
butter a chapter 2 was to 255 in either
could see Allah who lie on how you okay
you Latta who Zeenat Aman uh no no muff
is a Marathi moment it's Allah he's the
one the eternal subsisting no slumber
can see them not as a required rest twin
belongs everything the heaven
so if I carry forward the argument that
God can do anything and everything if I
agree then even God can tell a lie but
to tell a lie than godly the moment God
tells a lie he sees it to be God
similarly if you say that Almighty God
became a human being if I agree fine but
he loses the power of God if he loses
the power of God what is the use of
worshiping that women me like you and me
and then this is the remaining became
God if a human being can become Gautam
are you a now so can be God and my next
question is if God became human being
who control the world form of the TS
yeah if I agree with the Christian God
became human me who controlled the world
for those thirty days so they keep on
going in circles here and there you know
like the happening that and furthermore
if I agree with the argument of God can
do anything everything God can also do
injustice but to injustice is ungodly
Allah says in the Quran in surah nisa
chapter 4 40 Allah subhana WA Ta'ala is
never unjust in the least agree the
moment God does injustice he says to be
God if I agree with the argument God can
do anything everything what can he mean
forget but to forget is ungodly Allah
says in surah at the heart chapter 20
verse 52 that Allah never forgets the
moment God forgets we cease to be God
and that same argument God can even make
a mistake but to make mistake is ungodly
quran says in surah at the harbor 20 or
50 - Allah never makes a mistake the
moment God makes the mistakes is with
regard so no where does the Quran say
that God can do anything and everything
what does the Quran say in LA ala kulli
shayin Qadir for verily Allah has power
over all things in surah Baqarah chapter
- 106 instead of baqara chapter 2 109 in
surah bakra chapter 2 verse 2 84 in
surah al-e-imran chapter 3 verse 29 in
certain Hell chapter section in verse 77
instead of hatha chapter 35 verse number
one in several places of Quran says in
la jolla whole Asia and Cathy for warily
Allah has power over all things that is
a reason Allah says in surah borage
chapter 85 was 16
allies the door of all intends whatever
line means you can do but God will never
intend doing ungodly things like telling
a lie like making a mistake like being
no human being so what God intends we
can do but do say God can do anything
and everything it is illogical we want
to
and wrap it up with this tell us there
are thousands upon thousands watching us
and there are many sincere people out
there our brothers in humanity that are
listening and they hear this clear
message that you're explaining to them
it makes sense is rational it's not
something where you have to do a lot of
mental gymnastics to make fit and you
know what they want to get to Paradise
they want to do what the Creator wants
them to do give them some advice on how
they can come over and do and live that
life of all the messengers of God
worshipping God alone and at the end
being in Paradise and being our brothers
in faith can you give them some advice
the way that I gave for the non Muslim
brothers is that agree at least one
Scripture is the Word of God so
Christian would not mind saying that
okay what the Bible is the Word of God
they know not mind saying that whether
the Word of God the Muslim would not
mind saying that the Quran is the word
of God so I tell them what is common in
all the scriptures let us agree to
follow that what is different
what is differing we can discuss
tomorrow let us agree to follow
hundred-person what is common in all the
scriptures and when you decide you come
to know all the scripture say there is
one God all the conditions I get from
the Bible making it from the Vedas same
in the Quran all the scriptures say that
God has got no images he has got no
idols God does not beget have got no
children he have got no father all the
scriptures say that the last and final
messenger prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him Bible says in several places in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 18
verse number 18 in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter 18 verse number 19
in the book of Isaiah chapter 29 verse
number 12 in the Song of Solomon chapter
5 verse number 16 in the Gospel of John
chapter 14 verse 16 in the Gospel of
John chapter 15 verse 26 in the Gospel
of John chapter 16 verse number 7 in the
Gospel of John chapter 16 verse
similarity for that can go on and on and
on only quoting references you can give
what talks for us together almost all
awesome in the Bible we never talk for
us to get the muscle rasoolum in the
hindu scriptures so when it is clearly
mentioned in all the scriptures word as
one well got no images I've got no ideas
he's not a human being yeah I've got no
father he have got no son all the
scriptures say the last and final
messenger comics prophet vamos a la
Salim not only in the Christian
scripture or the Hindu scriptures in the
Parsee scriptures in the Buddhist
scriptures all these scriptures
so I request all the brothers from for
the world read your scriptures at least
agree to follow what is coming and then
you will come to know and you have to
believe if you're sincere that there is
no god but Allah and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is the messenger for
my trick now people love what you have
to say we have to come to an end there's
the top TV program in the world Islamic
program that everyone can come to
non-muslims and Muslims they want to
hear more of you and more of what you
have to say can you please tell us
really quickly we only got a few more
seconds peace TV the ps3 was launched
more than three years back and now
martial lights available on six
satellites it's available throughout the
world in North America and South America
it's available on galaxies eighteen
galaxies a Dalek CAT anyone has a dish
any one other dish they have to turn the
dish to one twenty-three point five
degrees west it's on the eighteen number
transponder and the frequency is double
one ninth double six so if you have a
dish you just turn it to 123 degrees one
twenty-three point five degrees west and
the frequency is double one nine double
six or if you want to maintain the old
channel it hardly cost about $200 to put
a new dish it's a free to a channel you
can watch it 24 us and inshallah you
will really appreciate it's free to a
thank you very much so may God Almighty
the creator of the heavens and earth
Allah reward you for general Russia
I mean devotion and thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
if you like what we had to say tune in
every week we're here trying to humbly
help you understand Islam and if you'd
like to learn more or if you like to
become our brothers sisters in faith
call the number on the screen 1 800 662
Islam until next time a Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you the DVDs for Dawa as
allah has said in the quran in surah now
16 125 will do alasa be lit up bigger
bill hikmah to invite all to the way of
your lord with wisdom beautiful
preaching and reason with them in ways
that are best and this is a great
opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as Allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world Islam submission
to the one God coming see
everyone's talking about if you find one
contradiction it can't be from God but
the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guy this way I will never
give up spreading this message okay you
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're going to live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believing Jesus you have
stepped outside of this nun you cannot
be a Muslim and attended our faith to
assalamu alaykum peace be on to what
your people kickback relaxes your chill
up with the Deen show God's will it
you're living it every day at night so
listen let me tell you a bit about envoy
your flight it's lame the true religion
every proper teachers I don't know what
Abraham Moses even Jesus is called to
worship the one true God and that's the
base of Islam Letty let her alone our
brothers from everywhere all around the
globe
coming to drop a bit and knowledge from
the comfort of your home so ladies and
gents brothers and sisters get ready
you're watching the teen show take it
away
Eddie